well it is time for drew's news and with
me at the desk the best co-pilot a girl
could ever ask for ross matthias
everybody
okay
first up i have to send a big
congratulations to
my cinematic soul mate adam sandler
yeah
page six reports that this is so wild
according to google they did a year in
search and the report is that adam
sandler had the most searched for style
of 2021
when it came to searches for celebrity
outfits adam beat everyone from britney
spears to harry styles
it turns out sandler chic is in rossi
will or is it i mean
we
love adam sandler right and he i think
he was sort of pandemic chic before
pandemic chic was a thing
when we all just sort of embraced
elastic from head to toe um
yes i think it certainly is a look
what's so funny is our first meeting
that adam and i had he was dressed
exactly like he is today
and that was 25 years ago so who knew
sandler was just ahead of the game yes
he was congratulations adam sandler i
love you adam all right uh next up you
know it's that time of year when we love
to snuggle up with our favorite holiday
movies and centurylink just crunch the
numbers to make this map of the most
popular 90s movies by state i feel like
steve kornacki right now on msnbc the
biggest winner of across the country was
home alone yeah no surprise there right
14 states
including florida michigan and new york
there were six states that loved the
nightmare before christmas one of the
states was your home state california
and my home state of washington
this was interesting they love
i'm bad in schwarzenegger and jingle all
the way
i don't know that i've actually seen
jingle all the way you know what i
haven't either but when i see
schwarzenegger on that poster looking
nuts wrapped up in christmas trees i'm
like that really is the visual
of how i feel during the holiday really
yeah just mayhem yeah well um it's not
just classics too bbc news reports there
are more christmas movies being made now
than ever before listen to this 200 new
christmas movies were made this year
hallmark alone made 42 of them and it
was a new record for them and lifetime
made 35 this year well you know who also
is in that game is netflix and i'm proud
to say that our dear friend and my
lifelong friend brook shields came here
to promote her movie a castle for
christmas which actually her and i shot
on this set
and it is number one on that one
congratulations i'm just so happy for
her yeah she deserves it i know she's so
nice she was here right here right here
and she was so nice greatest all right
well next it's the holiday party season
and we're gonna go
full on nuts but at the end of the night
how do you politely tell your guests we
have just had so much fun it has been
awesome but please god let's wrap this
up
um so huffpost asked people the exact
question how is the tactic you should
take to signal to party guests that it
is over
some take out the trash and start
cleaning up that's good that's one sign
others do a wardrobe change kind of
switching from a party outfit to comfy
sweats nope that's certainly a signal
some just slap their leg and say well
that was really fun stand up
and you know gives you that look of i
think we all know what i'm saying here
um rossi how do you wrap up an evening
oh i'm good really telling everything
because i don't you know that last
person who sticks around forever
it's time to go so i do this i'm like oh
it's all about the breath right you go
what's your day look like tomorrow and
then i say i go oh yeah i got an early
one so i'm so glad we did this
that's it and then they get it i'm so
glad we did this
this was so
fun it was so great to see you rossi i
think that one might be one for the
psychology books it's perfect it's
perfect it's like sweet gaslighting yeah
completely well you sound busy should
probably go to bed
oh my god i love it i have also taken
this tactic okay many times i've gone
into my room and shut the door no
you cannot do that well i used to party
with people who could party all night so
i had no choice
you and i could not be more different in
a million years i would never do that
and yet i know we represent the fact
that we don't have to be exactly the
same in this world and we can still get
along yes
but i will never do that to you i will
always get out i will promise next party
i come to your house i'm leaving early
all right i'm out you're not gonna have
to do that move hey i want to get your
um thoughts on this story singles you
know i've had to get super creative
right with dating and all the dating
habits over the past year and a half
well now there's a new word for it
refinery 29 says it's called spontaneo
dating like spontaneous dating well it
describes all the creative new types of
dates people have dreamed up because it
used to be like plain old drinks dinner
and a movie but now people are doing
things like picnics dated the climbing
gym long walks in the city an impromptu
rowboat adventure i don't like this
this gives me such anxiety i
i need a reservation
so i have reservations about this you
know
i don't want to walk around and oh now
we're in a hat store why are we doing in
a hat store i want to i want to know
what we're doing i want to do that oh my
god though if you're totally falling for
someone that hat store might be the
funnest place you've ever been you're
like and this one and this one cue the
movie mondo oh my
that's what you're god
about there's many ways uh to go about
it i think my biggest thing is am i
carrying my transport backpack with my
provisions for the day or am i keeping
it loose and fancy free with a little
thing like fanny pack and like sneakers
i hope you're a fan of packing it i do
love a fanny pack and a chance for it
and you know why
my hands are free
we'll be right back
[Music]
you